john well today the raiders start their
second campaign here in town
the team will open training camp on a
season full of hope
bianca holman is live at the team's
headquarters down in henderson with a
look at what's
what's happening later on today
hey good morning hector so today is more
like move-in day
here at the intermountain healthcare
performance facility so
the veterans the coaches they are all
making their way in
today for training camp and it's very
exciting matter of fact we want to show
you uh
the video that they release it's on
youtube they're ready for some tough
practices coming up so they call it
show up with a purpose that seems to be
the big theme around here right now
the team is young and talented players
we spoke with say they're excited to get
to
camp and to start working on the raiders
and to get back to the playoffs for the
first time since the 2016 season
we plan on building on the foundation
that we started last year
and the year prior and continuing to
build one of the best offenses in the
league
we feel like we can do that our
offensive line the guys that are
stepping in this year are
you know good players smart players or
hungry
of course offense really wasn't the
problem last year it was defense giving
up 30 points per game that gave raiders
fans
fits the first preseason game is less
than three weeks away the raiders will
host seattle
august 14th and that will be the first
big time nfl crowd ever
at allegiant stadium the regular season
kicks off on monday night football
with baltimore ravens coming to town
september 13th now the nfl has said that
it plans to host
fanned events at each team's training
camp the raiders they haven't officially
released those details just yet but of
course when we have them we will
definitely let you all know and keep you
updated
reporting live from henderson bianca
holmen 8 news now